camouflé en joyeuse bande de randonneurs
voici l'encadrement et huit joueurs de
l'équipe de france
cette semaine ils l'ont passée en grande
partie à récupérer la préparation
spécifique à la coupe du monde ce sera
pour plus tard les bleus profitent
ensemble de quelques jours de détente
mois le stage non plus n'est pas et pas
dans des conditions ils perdent
difficile oustric comme avec la fontaine
donc là en a on peut se permettre de
relâcher un peu psychologiquement donc
de souffler est simplement là en train
de charger une batterie une ambiance de
vacances pour éviter la réputation de
football
après on très longue scène un état
d'esprit convivial gourou pour intégrer
plus facilement le petit nouveau
djibril cissé à 20 ans le meilleur
buteur du dernier championnat différent
ça n'avait jamais été sélectionné
il a donc fait connaissance avec ses
futurs partenaires
je ne prendrai jamais un titre est
condamnatoire pour les deux derniers
jours retour progressif au bal un hôtel
de luxe à maurice devant des centaines
de supporters roger lemerre a
tranquillement diriger ses troupes pour
quelques exercices
conclusion en douceur pour un stage à
effectif réduit mais avec un objectif
atteint
une part de reconcentration sur l'équipe
de france
ils vont venir le pouls ils vont
transmettre aux camarades à leurs
camarades la semaine prochaine
le stage s'est donc terminée hier
désormais direction le centre de
clairefontaine un match amical face à la
belgique
mais là ils seront presque au complet et
l'ambiance sera moins décontractée la
compétition se rapproche dans vingt
jours exactement les bleus seront à
séoul pour jouer leur premier match de
la coupe du monde face au sénégal